the jurgen experience but you know the
since we're on this topic can we talk a
little bit of vaccines because i'm
it's something i've i have seen a lot of
misinformation
like
on
everywhere
facebook on you know different news
media outlets and and i think there's
really like some some main ones
that that i just feel are
causing harm
and so um
there's really eight of them we don't
need to talk about all of them but i
think the eight really are that you know
sars cove two is not that bad copa 19 is
not that bad and
you know vaccines basically don't
prevent transmission
spike protein from vaccines are
cytotoxic therefore they're really bad
um
that vaccines are going to cause
something called antibody dependent
enhancement which is going to make you
have a more severe disease
there's the vaccines are going to cause
infertility
there's the um
vaccines are going to cause a more
violent virulent
strain or variant
and then there's one more
that
alternatives to vaccines exist right now
that are just as good and i think that
there's a few of those that are really i
mean just like blatantly
they're wrong
all of them i think there but i mean you
know there's some that are more
important than others and i think that
i would like to talk about them um you
know i think first and foremost the
there's like two groups of people
mostly one take thinks copenhagen's bad
doesn't want it guess wants the vaccine
and the other one that thinks it's not
that bad and
uh that the vaccines may be harmful
and there's do you think that vaccines
are harmful to anyone
well of course
i mean do you know anyone that's had bad
reactions to vaccines i personally
interestingly the only i know a lot of
people that have gotten vaccinated and
the only person that i know that had
something was like
she had a headache for like a week and a
half and then it went away
um
oh no another person i knew had like
nausea for like a couple of weeks they
were like nauseous more more frequently
but it went away
um you know
do you think you would feel differently
if you knew someone that had a stroke or
someone who's had heart attacks
perhaps young people that have
well
it's hard to say so you know i do
people
react differently obviously when you're
giving you know
100 and
more than 169 million people are
vaccinated right i mean that's half our
adult population
is is vaccinated fully vaccinated with
copenhagen
and um it's not zero risk people are
some people are going to have an adverse
reaction and
they do it's a big world out there you
know like if you were to give 169
million people a peanut or a shellfish
like some people are going to have very
adverse reactions some people die like
it's a big world but you know with the
with the stroke or the heart attack
you know you have to like like so if
you're trying to compare for example
let's say you know you're looking at
actual cover 19
deaths and from heart attacks and
strokes and you're looking at the
vaccine adverse events reporting site
there's right and and that as well
you know
you have to realize that basically in
the united states like in 2017 there was
a publication in the journal of
circulation someone dies from
cardiovascular disease every 30 seconds
in the united states like every 30
seconds most of those people are above
the age of 50 and certainly most are
above 65. but every 30 seconds someone's
dying from cardiovascular disease every
40 seconds someone in the united states
has a stroke
every four minutes they die from a
stroke but this is also very very rare
in young people particularly young
healthy people but one thing that has
occurred in young healthy people they've
been vaccinated as myocarditis and some
people have had blood clots like quite a
few blood clots and
there's speculation right the salk
institute released that paper about the
uh spike protein
causing uh some sort of deterioration of
the blood vessels did you read that i
looked at the spike i've been looking at
a lot of the um spike protein and that's
from covet 19 they're discussing it
they're talking about from yeah from the
actual disease itself yes so um you know
first of all like they're
you have to like there's
you're either going to get infected with
cyrus grove 2 most people are going to
be eventually we're all going to be
exposed to it so you're either going to
be vaccinated when you're exposed to it
or not
and
people are dying from heart attacks and
blood clots and even people are getting
myocarditis like 100 full times more
than vaccines like
the the myocarditis link from
the mrna specifically the mrna vaccines
is real and i think the last i saw it
was like 50 per million which is still
rare and it's happened to two people
that i know
it so
up until then and actually now that you
asked me um i forgot i had a um someone
who's a supporter
i talked about vaccines in one of my q
as i do and they went and got it and
they were younger and ended up having
some kind of myocarditis so i do know
someone that had i don't know them but
they emailed me now what happens if you
have that and like
how do you recover from that but you
realize it's happening to young people
so myocarditis is caused by two things
one by
inflammation
two by direct viral infection and it's
more common in adolescents and young
people and it's an enlargement of the
heart it's inflammation of the heart can
lead to that yeah but it's it's
happening in young athletes with covid19
like and it's happening
like more frequently than people that
are getting vaccinated so it's still
like well if the person that got
vaccinated look it is a risk but it's
still pretty rare and it also is
treatable in most cases they treat it
like within a few days and it's isolated
why do you think that people like there
are people that are completely
asymptomatic when they get coveted or if
they do get it's very mild do you think
that's because they have a lower viral
load that they've been
infected with or do you think it's their
immune system that fights it off like
what do you think is happening it could
be any and all of those things a
combination of them and you know
but so like even if you think
you know if you're looking at just like
the most extreme part of like the deaths
right you know you've got like over 624
000 deaths in copen 19. most of those
deaths are happening in people over the
age of fifty
um
and if you look at like most of them
have four plus comorbidity factors right
isn't that the average i don't know if
it's four plus a three average for i
think the comorbidities increase yeah i
think
what the number of comorbidities are in
terms of like uh the deaths it used to
be 2.6 but i think they raised it to
four
really the number of them before okay
so i might be wrong but i know it was at
least two points right so then there's
the argument well i'm healthy i don't
have comorbidities right i mean so so
what what should i do like should i you
know get vaccinated or or should i be
exposed to the virus and i think there's
a lot of evidence and there's multiple
lines of evidence one
you know
there are people with mild symptoms that
are getting post-acute cobalt syndrome
they're getting this what people call it
long-haul covered and a lot and the
majority of people what do you think
that is what is post what is long haul
covet i don't know what it is i think it
depends on the the symptoms i think
there could be a variety of causes for
it um you know so there are people and
most of us this is happening in
teenagers to like 50. most of the people
that are older are not getting this
long-haul code but it's like happening
in people that are mostly not being
hospitalized
people that don't get hospitalized
originally like they have mostly like
pretty mild symptoms in some cases even
asymptomatic you know there was a study
published in the lancet like
last year
showing there was a seven-fold increase
in stroke incidents in people under 50
in the united states compared to the
year before that before the pandemic
start and that is probably because the
spike protein that causes this
deterioration of the blood vessels and
blood clots is that what it is from the
from the virus well i don't know what it
is i mean there's lots of things you
know viral infections themselves can
cause hypercoagulation they can cause
blood clots like just like that's like
known from other viruses like that's
something there's inflammation
without the spike protein so let's okay
i feel like i haven't got to address
everything but let's talk about the
spider real quick i think this four
points out where i would find this
information i hope that's the spot yeah
there is an average of 4.0 additional
conditions or causes of death for data
on deaths involving
covet 19 by time period jurisdiction and
other health conditions
this is only five percent the covert was
the only cause and then so for only five
percent of the covet does covet 19 was
the only cause mentioned so out of those
600 thousand people that died only five
percent died just from covet 19.
well i mean so you have people that are
coping 19 is going to make their
comorbidities worse and and that could
be the same for a vaccine it could be
the same for anything right i mean so
like something that's going to activate
the immune system yeah but i've the the
concern is with what vaccines the
negative effects that what people are
worried about i think is young people
that are healthy that have negative
effects
like that have had strokes or that have
had
thrombosis or myocarditis and those
issues right well i think you know again
if you look at the data
you know young people are also
experiencing those things at a higher
rate and are those all the people with
the co-morbidities like i don't know you
know like i i'm not sure
but
it seems as though no matter which way
you look at it like it it's it is worse
to be exposed to that virus and like how
do you know that person that had that
myocarditis wouldn't have had it x-fold
worse with the with the coba 19 because
it's been shown to happen in young
healthy athletes you know and people
have been shown in large numbers like
the
more more so more so more so than the
vaccines that we were saying yes i'm
saying that it's happening myocarditis
is from the vaccines it's happening in
younger people at a higher rate than
from the vaccines do we have accurate
data do you think about how many
myocarditis instances we have from the
vaccine
well you could argue there's an under
reporting um i think people
so anyone can submit data to the to the
bears and i think when it comes to
someone who's younger
they're more likely i mean so healthcare
professionals have to submit to the
bears if there's like something that's
life-threatening some which myocardials
could be or if it's death or something
that's like you know changes their daily
functions like
congenital effects
yes they are if they are
but if uh do they how do they know that
myocarditis is caused by the vaccine it
they don't but if it if the person had
gotten vaccinated and by the way there's
no time constraint like it's not like oh
if they've only been you know vaccinated
within like in two months
like they're supposed to they're
supposed to submit to theirs like if
someone was vaccinated and then
something yes is there encouragement or
discouragement to submit to theirs i
don't know i don't know but i mean
you know if you again even just looking
at the deaths in every age group even
like you know people that are in my age
group 40 to 49 you know there's 20 000
deaths that have been linked to the
confirmed kova 19 cases right whereas
you know in various it's 200.
for people with comorbidities obviously
it's a real issue
yeah i don't know if that's if that's
always the case but yes definitely with
people with comorbidities because
according to this what we pulled up it's
five percent that are dying just of the
covid
95 have an average of four comorbidities
okay well if that's true for all ages
um then you know yes people with
comorbidities are more likely to die but
also younger people i like i said
they're more likely to get you know
these long-haul symptoms where i've
known so many people you know that
they're they've they've gotten like
their loss of smell or taste has been
like several months and there's now
studies showing that you know if you
there was a huge study out of the
biobank um uk biobank data where the
where right before the pandemic started
mris were done brain scans on like
almost a thousand people was like over
800. and then the pandemic hit
people got covered some people didn't
whatever so
they brought these these the same cohort
of people back in for a brain scan
and you know basically they
corrected for people so they had people
that they compared people that were the
same age same gender same sex
and and then they um
also time between scans and they found
that both mild and severe cover 19 cases
caused a atrophy in the gray matter
region of the brain it was worse in
people that had it more severe right
understandable but people that had mild
cases that didn't go to the hospital
had it how many people did they study
with this it was over 800 yeah i mean
you know it's
you need you need more data to confirm
but i mean were these people did they
stratify it by age did age gender
ethnicity
health i don't know
did they have comorbidities did they
factor that in they had people that age
the same age you know as the people
didn't get code and they didn't have it
i mean you know this is several months
this is just months after i don't know
about the health did they monitor their
nutrition or find out what kind of
supplements they were i don't know i
don't i don't know if any of that data
was was you know in it but do you think
that data would be a factor at all
i don't know because i know people that
supplement that exercise that have had
um were diagnosed with they had a mild
case and they were diagnosed with pots
you know post
postural orthostatic tachycardia
syndrome where their heart was racing
like tachycardia was racing just control
like uncontrollably they were dizzy
couldn't had no energy i mean this was
months and they finally got diagnosed
there's like a lot of people coming out
with this but you know do you know
anybody that had covid and got through
it with almost no symptoms at all and
was very mild
um well yeah no symptoms at all but the
people that i do know most of them had
some kind of weird taste
issue like or smell thing for like weeks
and weeks but um
but you don't know anybody that didn't
have that
um
i don't because most the people i know
that had it
lost their smell watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify